[Music]
you've seen politics and national
borders change all the time but have you
ever witnessed a continent literally
breaking apart well it's possible and
it's happening to Africa right now in
2005 a 60 kilometer long stretch of the
continent cracked open over a period of
just ten days and it hasn't stopped
expanding since eventually the landmass
will break right off giving birth to a
brand new ocean how soon will this
happen and what does it mean for the
people of Africa this is what if and
here's what would happen if the African
continent broke apart the face of our
planet is continually changing thanks to
the shifting of tectonic plates but it's
rarely this noticeable in the years
since 2005 more cracks in the earth have
opened up in several countries
throughout the African continent
sparking fear among their populations
but as scary as the fractures may seem
experts say they could teach us a lot
about how our world was formed have you
ever heard of the East African Rift
neither and most people in Ethiopia
until the ground started cracking
beneath their feet the East African Rift
is an active continental rift zone in
East Africa and judging by the blank
look on your face it may require more of
an explanation before we go any further
okay so the rigid outer layer of the
earth is called the lithosphere and it's
broken up into many tectonic plates
tectonic plates are basically large
slabs of solid rock that move relative
to each other at varying speeds when
these plates move apart from each other
they cause fractures to be formed at
their boundaries the land remaining in
between the two plates starts to sink
and forms what's known as a Rift Valley
this can lead to new boundaries being
created between plates in the case of
the East African Rift the African
tectonic plate is breaking up into two
smaller ones the Somali and Nubian
plates
so what happens when these plates
completely break off from each other
well for one thing we won't be around to
see it despite the rapid appearance of
the surface cracks geologists say that
the continent won't fully break apart
for about 10 million years they're
currently spreading apart at a rate of 6
to 7 millimeters a year so don't hold
your breath as the plates continue to
pull away from each other the Rift
Valley will sink deeper and deeper and
water from the Red Sea will flood in to
create a new ocean Africa will become a
lot smaller as parts of southern
Ethiopia and Somalia will drift off to
form a new island what does this mean
for all of us in the mean time well
African residents who live along the
Rift can expect more disturbances cracks
in their highways and cities and the
emergence of vast canyons where there
weren't any before but it's not all bad
news
in fact most geologists are pretty
excited about studying the whole process
they believe it can lead to some pretty
groundbreaking information about how our
Earth's surface is shaped and how
earthquakes and volcanic eruptions work
one day all of our continents will look
completely different but that's a story
for another what-if
[Music]